كاك كاك صو صو صو
أَنَا دَجَاجَةْ نحن الكتاكيت
نقضى اليوم جرى وتنطيط
من منكم أشطر كتكوت
يبقى طول اليوم نشيط
صو صوصو أنا الكتكوت
أنهي طبقي أشرب لبنى
آكل توت (..بالبسكوت )
أفطر في وقت مضبوط
ترضي ماما طبعا أفعل
ألعب بهدوء وخفوت
اهتفوا له اهتفوا له
ما أجمل ما كان يقول
كااك كااك صو صو صو
كااك كااك كااك صو صو صو
أنا دجاجة نحن الكتاكيت
نقضي اليوم جري وتنطيط
أغسل وجهي بعد النوم
أؤدي فرضي المعلوم
أحمل أغراضي وأقلامي
ولموعد مدرستي أقوم
تكتب حقا
أكتب أقرأ
ترسم أيضا
وبه الأكفأ
ألف باء
أكتب أبدأ
لو نادت ماما ما ردك
سألبي لا لا أتلكأ
اهتفوا ا له اهتفوا له
ما أجمل ما كان يقول
كااك كااك صو صو صو
أنا دجاجة نحن الكتاكيت
نقضي اليوم جري وتنطيط
أصفر ريشي زاه اللون
أستيقظ وأمشط شعري
أغسل أسناني ويدي
وأساعد في المنزل أمي
ماذا تفعل
أحمل طبقي
ماذا أيضا
أغسل كوبي
ولجيرانك
لا اؤذيهم
لو جاء ضيوف للمنزل
أجلس بهدوئي أكرمهم
اهتفوا له اهتفوا له
ما أجمل ما كان يقول